so
so this is signal processing with web
audio i'm jordan santel
and so a quick introduction with the web
audio it's a relatively new api
all major browsers support this except
ie but they just announced this week
that they will support this in the next
version which is awesome
so this uh audio api is a
modular routing api used for
manipulating audio
um it's used in games uh synthesizers
and audio production tools
so what is the signal processing
component of this
so signal processing is the theory of
manipulating and analyzing a signal in
the case of web audio
the signal is an audio buffer so just a
giant array of
data quick about me
um i love this gif so i work for mozilla
on the sdk team for the sdk for add-ons
and
developer tools and also the web audio
developer tools
so the web audio api it is a route-based
audio api for processing
audio signals um it's constructed as a
directed acyclic graph
so the audio flows from source nodes to
the destination node and along the way
it gets either transformed or analyzed
and manipulated
and all the audio nodes are created
within a sandbox
called the audio context all nodes must
live within a context and the context
decides
things like what's the sample rate of
this whole
graph so it can be a little confusing
because it's
unlike most other new web apis so
there are four node types these aren't
official these are just ways to classify
them
to better understand the api so there
are source nodes
and so source nodes emit sound
through the origin of some kind of
signal we can make a
source nodes out of things like the
webrtc audio stream
uh html audio element
oscillator and a this last one
something else and so this is where the
origin of sound so
the sound travels through the uh
directed graph
and it could possibly be either
transform or analyzed so a
transformation audio node
would be something like delay filter
compression something that will
transform the audio signal to
so it sounds differently an analyzation
node
uh it doesn't affect the actual signal
it just lets us
better interpret it and get information
about it so we would do that for
something like
uh an audio visualization
and finally we have a destination node
and anything that we want to hear
must ultimately arrive at the
destination so in this example we have
three sources
and they could be anything really and it
goes through some filtering distortion
panning
reverb and ultimately a compressor and
the destination node in the web audio
api
is a abstraction for our sound card so
if we
if we have a source node and we want to
hear it whether it's a
mp3 file or whatever it ultimately has
to flow into the
the destination node so we can actually
hear it
so if this still doesn't make sense
here's a viking metal band
so uh you go to a concert the guitarist
is
setting up and the new thing of the
guitar is an
uh source node this is where the sound
originates
the signal travels from the guitar
through the cable into
a this is a viking metal band so they
have a lot of distortion
so they to transform the clean guitar
signal
it goes into a distortion pedal makes it
heavy much louder
you know things like that it transforms
the signal and then ultimately from the
distortion pedal go into an amplifier so
we can actually perceive it
and you know it will be a good concert
another way to think about this flow
this audio context flow
is similar to uh middleware
uh in routing so like express.js
middleware
um you can think of a request as a
source so
when someone requests some file from a
server
that's the origin of this process and
then ultimately you could go through
several
pieces of middleware when this
middleware can transform or analyze
the request throughout so if you want to
you know
have a middleware check make sure the
user is logged in or something for
some resource then the middleware would
analyze that and determine whether
it should proceed and ultimately you get
a
response which is the final destination
for that
so a really simple example um
first we create the audio context again
all nodes and everything must live
within audio context and you have to
have the context to create these nodes
as well
so we instantiate an audio context and
create an oscillator and a gain node
to use the node types i explained before
an oscillator is a source node so it
creates
a for example a sine wave so that's
where the sound originates and it can
travel through a gain node
and gain is a fancy word for how loud
something is
so it originates for the signal
originates from an oscillator travels
through a gain node since we connected
our oscillator to our gain node
and then the gain node connected to the
destination so we can actually hear it
and then we have to start the oscillator
so here's an example make sure we're
quiet
so it's a really annoying sound so
here's an example of the audio tools in
firefox which just
draws the context graph so we can see
what node is connected to which node we
can also edit things
so in the last slide we solve an
oscillator node that's connected to the
gain node
which is connected to the destination at
the far right the
other two nodes the analyzer and script
processor are just for the demos to
display the time domain data so it
that's
obviously a sine wave very fast
so oscillators uh create these tones
with uh
periodic cycles so assign and they're
created by some kind of equation
so a sine wave is created by the
mathematical
sine function um
and all these waves are periodic waves
so they're
repeated patterns so let me make sure
there's other type of oscillators on
sine wave we can have
a triangle
and it's named that way because it looks
like a triangle
square wave is that too loud
excellent and my favorite sawtooth
um and you can see how these uh waves
are named because they actually look
like the object that they were named
after
so if those familiar with
electronica music or synthesizers or you
know if you ever played a game boy
a lot of these sounds are the foundation
of any synthesizer
synthesizers use these basic waveforms
to construct more
abstract and complex shapes and we'll do
a little bit of that in a bit
so we can change the type so right now
it's a sawtooth and we also change the
frequency
so the frequency is mentioned in hertz
and
it's a unit that represents how many
times per second this periodic wave uh
cycles so at 440 hertz uh
this shape is repeated 440 times per
second
and that's what we perceive as pitch so
is a you know concert a4
let's
so if i drop this an octave to 220
we can see we actually uh perceive a
lower pitch and the
it's a much you can see the cycles are a
little bit slower it's still 220 times a
second but
if we drop this to something inaudible
like below 20 hertz
five let's say
we can actually perceive that because
we're not robots
right yeah we're scaring all the animals
right now
so let me so i mean that's a really
terrible sound
no one wants to listen to pure sine
waves all the dogs are angry right now
so we can uh manipulate these uh signals
in a bunch of different ways
so one technique is amplitude modulation
in which we want to change an amplitude
is the uh
so how high the signal is
and which we perceive as uh volume
so if we want a really loud sine wave we
would have
really large cycles one quite sine wave
would be
a really subtle wave so what we can do
is in the previous example we connected
one audio node to another audio node but
we can also connect audio nodes
which again is just this pure signal to
an audio parameter
so in amplitude modulation so we have a
carrier signal
which this is our pitch same thing we
did in the last one so
let's assume this is a 440 sine wave we
also have a modulating
sine wave signal that affects some other
property in the audio context so this
modulating sine wave signal is much
lower frequency than the carrier signal
so we can use this modulating sine wave
signal to
tween between a loud sound and a soft
sound
so if we combine these two signals or
have the moduling sine wave signal
affect
the subsequent gain we can see
in the last image as the modulating sine
wave signal approaches negative 1
the carrier signal gets much quieter
so implement something like this similar
to the previous one
we have a an oscillator or carrier
signal connected to our gain node and
our gain nodes connected to our context
destination
just like we had in the last example we
also have another oscillator our
modulator
uh that's connected to the gain node's
gain
auto audio parameter so as the modulator
uh goes between one and negative one
it'll tween the
the volume of our signal so it's a
little bit more interesting
so it'll sound something like like a i'm
going to make a lot of weird sounds
throughout this
so i'll be like because we're pulsating
the
volume so
so
so in this in this graph we have our
oscillator again gain node
connected to our destination node
but this oscillator down here this is
our uh modulating signal
so right now it's only a frequency of
five so this is only repeating five
times per second
so this means it's going the carrier
signal is going to go between
uh full gain and no gain uh
five times per second so if we change
the modulating signal
we can change how often this
pattern is repeated so
sorry about that so it changes to one
so only once per second is this gain
changing and we can see it actually
being visualized
as the volume decreases there's no
activity in the time domain data
you can do this with other
waves on the sine wave so we got
sawtooth wave as our carrier signal
which sounds like a broken game boy
um so yeah so we can use amplitude
modulation to make things a little bit
more interesting because no one wants to
hear
pure sine tones
another thing we do is a frequency
modulation um
is where instead we're instead of
modifying the amplitude or the volume
we're modifying the actual pitch or
frequency of the carrier signal so same
idea
as amplitude modulation so our
modulating sine wave signal is
changing the frequency or how often the
cycle of the carrier signal is repeating
so we see in this example as the
moduling sine wave approaches negative
one
the frequency of the carrier signal uh
increases so the distance between each
cycle
is lessened which we perceive as pitch
so if we're going between a lower pitch
and a higher pitch in a synthesizer
we'll get some like weird 80s sci-fi
like
i've been waiting to do that so
i think i did it better but it sounded
pretty good
so this is uh pretty much the same
example except we're
gonna go to the code real quick so same
thing except instead of connecting our
modulating oscillator into our gain
node's audio parameter we're connecting
it to the
carrier's frequency so as the modulating
signal goes up and down so does the
carrier's frequency
as you've seen this sweet example i will
have an album just of that
and so the only difference thing here is
that our modulating oscillator is also
going into a
gain node just to increase the change
so if we change the modulating uh
oscillator's gain node to one
it's not that much of a difference it's
not changing the frequency too much but
if we crank it up to
we get some weird stuff going on and we
see like
again this is modulating the frequency
so we see the sine wave the carrier
signal
um crushing together when it's a higher
frequency and expanding
when it's a lower frequency so we see
this kind of like breathing effect
so again you're not going to listen to
you know that's
that still doesn't sound good but again
this is the foundation of
you know any kind of like electronic
music synthesis
and so notice that we're also using
really low frequencies for the
modulating signal this is two hertz
humans can hear between 20-ish hertz and
like 20 000
hertz so we can't really perceive this
uh
this signal even though because it's
affecting it so if you increase the
the modulating signal to something that
we can perceive
things get weird so let's make this
so the kerosene was 440. and if we make
the modulating signal
100 so that's like a
bass note on a bass guitar
so we get this weird modulation effect
so like if you want to pretend you're a
dalek you do something like this
and so the reason why we use low
frequencies
for a modulating
so we can't perceive we just maybe we
just want a subtle effect
like a use often like tremolo phasing uh
vibrato
um we don't want to perceive that so
this is called a
lfo uh not the 90s boy band but a low
frequency oscillator
so we don't perceive we just uh we have
some kind of pattern
so we can like repeat amplitude
modulation or frequency modulation or
some other effect
so and we can also
modulate other audio parameters not just
frequency
and amplitude so we can plug this in
we can pipe an oscillator into a filter
a delay node
anything that we want so we can get more
interesting things
otherwise we just sound like you know
game boys
so that sounds really cool in here
um so for this example
so again similar to the other ones
except right now we have two oscillators
two carrier signals one at a
40 hertz a sawtooth and a square wave at
80 hertz
and those are octaves apart so it
doesn't sound awful
going into a filter node and a filter um
you know think of like an array filter
function filtering is kind of
pretty much equalizing so right now this
filter node
a biquad filter uh is a low pass type
so it has a frequency value and right
now it's at 500.
so this means that any frequency higher
than 500
is uh significantly reduced so we only
really hear the
notes below 500.
and the modulation that we're performing
here we have again an oscillator node
at one uh one hert one hertz
um so this will the modulation happen
once per second
and that's being pumped into the biquad
filters frequency property
so what is being you know animated or
tweened or modulated
is the low pass filter frequency so as
the sine wave
continues we're we're going between only
allowing just the low frequencies
which humans have a hard time perceiving
so it sounds quieter than higher
frequencies
into allowing more and more frequencies
and then oscillating back
so that's what we hear here
so it's just going cycling over letting
lower frequencies
only lower frequencies and letting more
and more frequencies in and then going
back
so
sorry so in this example same thing
slightly different properties for the
oscillator node
except we also have two modulating
signals at this point
one is controlling the
filter node just as in the last one so
0.5 hertz so this is happening
once every two seconds and a gain note
to increase it
and then we have an oscillator in there
that's controlling the gain so we're
also doing the filter modulation
as well as amplitude modulation
okay so so and we can also
so again this isn't you know this is
just like a simple example of some you
know
synthesis that can be performed and we
can hook this up to a
uh you know a touch interface like a
keyboard or something and trigger
whether or not these notes stop and
start and deal with sustain if you
a user holds in a note and things like
that we can also
just automate everything and just
compose a song that
requires no human input so we can do
things like
so and this again we're just dealing
with
i'm a composer so we're just dealing
we just started with two oscillator
nodes one's a sawtooth one's a square
wave
and so we came from this like game boy
sound into you know something that could
possibly be
in a a song or an album or a concert
because we just made dubstep
so thanks everyone um
so i'm jay sentell on github and twitter
bug me if you have any questions about
web audio stuff
or the firefox dev tools for audio uh
it's coming out in firefox 32
um and still have no idea what
we're doing with it completely but any
feedback would be awesome so we can make
it better
so we have more you know game developers
using web audio api
synthesizer makers and you know audio
production engineers so
thanks guys
so
you